こんにちは
始めシャツようです
うっ
うううう
なぜ今まで
僕が
東京に行っていた時
そして
移動中今塚 dell デスクトップがパ息を伺う前まで
ana poooo poooo
今まで僕がブルが youtube をやって言ってここまで来れたのは間違いなく
この macbook pro のおかげです
でも今日でお別れですこの子は
長い間
僕を助けてくれたいつ買ったんだっけ
作った交換だよ
ああああああ
ゆずちゃんチャーはカンガーどこまで1位タイだよ
本当にずっと二人になりました音楽的に編集し始めたのはこのパソコン買ってからなの
でちょっといつ買ったかなんか情報でないかな
2014年ですね2014年ということは2年間ぐらいかな
多分に面会ぐらいですね2010年のモデルさんで多分2年間くらいずっとこの
パソコンで無駄にパソコンに負荷を与えるような編集をしてもらう
って本当にお世話になったと思っておりますじゃあすごいよ
動画の編集ってすごい負荷がかかるんですよ思って子供さんも限界まで頑張ってくれて
たんですけど本当の限界と言いますか中身も多くなったのもあるし
マウスで動かしてから5秒後ぐらいに動くとかちょっと上させるちょっと考え中マーク
で20秒止まったりそういうことが非常に多くなってきて
いろいろな髪消したりグリーンとがしてみたんですけどあんまり変わらなくてもう
つ妙かなと思いましてまあこの動画をもちましてこの海文この
マック物故の macbook pro とお別れします
運送本当にありがとう本当にありがとうございます
なぜかな僕はここまで作ってくれたパソコンといったらもうこいつらんで彼の遺志を
引き継ぐ形で本土からこのパソコンを使っていこうと思います
はあああああ
ん
macbook pro の新型てございますこれがなんかすごい的ないいタイミング
で出たなと思ったので買ったんですけど結構いろんなユーチューバーさん使ってて
ちょっと出遅れたんですけども発売したと同じくらいに買って今届きました何で俺
爪楊枝だけんだろうか非常に悲しいですよほんとずっとね使ってきた
このパソコンはいろんな思い出が入ってるでもねやっぱり人間はまあ
3進まなきゃダメなんですよ
これは開けていきましょうはマックフックが過ぎた添田
ん
うん
あれマックの匂いがしないぞまあでましたこちらでございますこれもこれこれこれ zs
とこれはぜだわ
うわぁ色がすごい薄いしたいそして薄いですな相手指でこちらの真琴の macbook
pro でございますあとはなんかアレとアレとアレがって言ってますこれでその途中
から遅くなったからもうちょっとスペックを良くしようと思って15インチこれよ1個
大きいタイプのヤツを買った予定なんですが
15日てるね合ってる合ってるアイパーでかいんだ
サイズがやっぱり日となるぐらいちょっとコツのが大きいですこれでわかると思うん
ですけれどもかなり薄くなっております
や外でもねはちょっとだけだという理由だけてみましょうか
誰だこといたずらしてさもう歩みで今回すごいのはですねここですね
動くんじゃ冊したらうんうううううっ
ずメって言ったら勝手にここに変換が出てきますので見たらここで入力できるのかを
増産
おっこれがあるって便利から可愛いなぁこんな可愛いキーボードあります
なってきたらそのまま貼り付けれるというやつでございます
南かやべすっげす動画みたいになっちゃった愛と指で新しいパソコンを買ったという話
でございました
やっぱりロースペレットどうしてもねノートパソコン dell 編集がメインになっ
てくるんでねえやつを買いました
打ったりせずにし buzz
今までありがとうな
楽福を君と動画を作れて
僕は楽しかったよ何言ってんだよ
お外がいなかったら今の俺はいいねぇよとばにスペック不足で止まったりしたけど
ごめんね何言ってんだ
お前はお前のスペックを最大限に活かして俺をサポートしてくれた
それだけで俺が十分だった俺は忘れもしないぜ
お前と作った
たくさんの動画を僕こそ
最後まで使ってくれて
ありがとー
プーマ
ルアー